most small entrepreneurs try and get
customers to make sales bigger
entrepreneurs try to make sales to get
customers and the difference is one
person is all about trying to get to the
money as fast as possible what do I need
to say to get this person say yes what
do I need to say to get this person to
buy right how do I get the money the
other way is how do I make some sort of
exchange so that I can now create a long
time relationship with this customer and
continue to provide value over time one
has a compounding View and perspective
on time and value and the other is
short-sighted and I can tell you the
difference between the people who are
millionaires that I'm friends with and
people who are billionaires that I am
friends with this is probably one of the
most fundamental differences and so I
was talking to a friend of mine who's
worth it and he was saying if it's not
going to grow on its own over time it's
not worth doing I really sat with that
for a second and it was like if you put
in a one-time effort this is how people
who are the ultra wealthy thing if you
put one-time effort into something and
it compounds over time then that is an
Enterprise or product that they want to
continue to invest in on the flip side
if you have to consistently show up and
consistently promote and consistently
get out there and sell and sell and do
all this stuff then what ends up
happening is that the product itself is
not good enough right people in and of
themselves are not referring business
need motivation watch it top 10 with
believe Nation hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because in my
first business I quit on my business
partner I was making 300 bucks a month
and I didn't have the motivation to keep
going and the thing that got me through
was studying the stories of
entrepreneurs who've had massive success
and I hope that in sharing these stories
with you you find a motivation to keep
going and if I'm being honest I still
need the source for myself today too so
today let's learn from one of the best
Alex hermosi and my take on his top 10
rules of success enjoy
let me give you three questions that
really changed and hopefully will alter
your perspective like they did mine
around product and service and so the
first is
if I have an existing product or service
and I were to make it 10 times more
expensive so really think about the
price so or you can say a hundred
thousand dollars or a million dollars
whatever it is right just a huge number
and if that's how much I were charging
for it what would I need to do
what would the experience need to be
what would the product need to deliver
in order for it to be worth that much
what happens you start thinking in a
very different type of mindset about how
much value you have to create right and
so that is the first question that I ask
there's two more and the third one's my
favorite I'll get to in a second
second question I ask is
if this product that I have cost one
tenth as much as it does right now but I
had to make it better than it currently
is
what would I need to do what one-time
assets would I need to create that would
consistently provide value that I could
do at scale that could I could do
profitably right so
first question If This Were 10 times
expensive or a hundred thousand or a
million dollars is what I charge for my
product
what would it need to be what would the
experience need to be and what value
would I need to deliver in order for it
to be worth that much
the second question is if it were
one-tenth the cost but I had to make it
better than my current product or
service what else would I create or do
or make in order to facilitate that
outcome
and the third question which is probably
my favorite which I think underpins the
entire ideology that that I'm hitting on
here is if I had a business and I were
only allowed to sell one more customer
and the rest of the growth of my
business had to come from that customer
without me asking as in that that
customer's experience was so remarkable
was so positive was so amazing that they
they alone had to own their own volition
tell other people about my service
what would need to happen
what would need to happen to create that
experience and when thinking about all
three of these product frames I like
them because they kind of hit on
different aspects of the product the
first question which is a hundred
thousand dollar million dollar question
hits on value which is how do I create
the most value in the product itself
the second question hits on the profit
of the product because if it's one-tenth
the cost and I have to make it better
this means I don't have to do high
margin one-time investment type things
to make the entire product more valuable
right so that hits on profit so first is
the value of the product the second is
the profit to me right as a business
owner and then the third question hits
on the experience which is what's the
customer experience which is everything
else that surrounds the product that
we're selling or service that we're
selling right what is the experience
that has to occur in order for this
customer to become a raving fan that
it's so good that they remark about it
they cannot help themselves but remark
about it and what's interesting is that
every super wealthy person that I know
pretty much exclusively talks about
product and usually the really small
people that I know only talk about
promotion and promotion should really
only exist to get your product right and
then once it is right then you can juice
it and then let it go and take care of
itself and the reason that it's so
important at least in my opinion is that
if you think about the six ways of
getting customers right and if you don't
know what those are it's paid media
earned media So Paid media is
advertising right and promotions uh
earned media is following so right if
you have any kind of organic following
the third is through your contact list
so people on your phone and your email
list Etc that you already own their
contact information the fourth is
through manual outbound so that's DMS
cold emails cold calls code all of that
stuff where you reach out to people
the fifth is through Affiliates so
Partners who can promote your stuff and
the sixth which is the most powerful and
the only one that compounds
is Word of Mouth so think about that for
a second every of the other five ways of
acquiring customers is not compounding
those are linearly scaled right it means
if you double the amount of outbound
people you have you double the amount of
customers that you get if you double
your ad spend you might be able to
double the amount of customers you get
sometimes it's less than that but you
get the idea they skill relatively
linearly right
whereas Word of Mouth referrals which is
the sixth way of getting customers is
the only one that compounds it
multiplies rather than is additive all
right if you get two people to tell two
people and those people tell two people
that it continues to compound and that
is what creates Enterprise Value that is
what creates an enduring thing and that
is what when you spend the extra time to
make the product so good that people
have to tell their friends about it then
that's where you get the unending scale
and also is where all the profit is
right you don't have to worry about the
churn as much because the product's so
good you don't have to worry about the
negative reviews because the product's
so good you don't have to worry about
customers bad math because instead
they're telling their friends about how
good you are and
this has been one of the shifts that has
been most helpful for me and honestly
what I when I look back on my own
trajectory how much I talk about
promotion in the beginning of my career
versus now I talk so much more about
people and product the real nuts of this
is that
everything that the ultra wealthy do is
compounding it grows with time where
time becomes an asset instead of a
liability and if everything you do you
have to go out and get more business go
out and get more business go out and get
more business right it means that it
requires effort every single day whereas
if you put a lot of front-end effort
which is the investment which is the
patience right to make the thing that
much better in the beginning
then it will pay you in dividends over
time and most people skip that step
because they just want to make the first
sale they're just trying to get a
customer to make a sale rather than
trying to make a sale to get a customer
rule number two focus on your Niche
there's a tweet by Layla my wife she
said like stop listening to people about
like sorry stop listening to people
about how to play the game who've never
been anywhere but the sidelines and the
problem is too many of the people who
are watching this right now y'all are on
the sidelines and have always been on
the sidelines and are trying to pick a
niche to get into to sell how to do the
niche well that's dumb you've never done
it so a lot of times people are trying
to skip to a higher leverage opportunity
without having done the requisite work
of understanding the niche which is why
the Y combinator people look for like if
you want to make a software in the
payment space we'd love to see that you
have experience in the payment space
because there's so much stuff that you
don't know that you know when you
actually spend three five you know years
doing something in an industry you
understand the lingo you understand the
Avatar you understand the problems and
you can see opportunities if you have an
entrepreneurial hat on there's always
problems in every industry which means
there's always opportunity and
fundamentally business is just solving
problems that exist with it and making
sure the math makes sense like that's
literally it it's like where is there a
problem how much did they think this is
a problem and is there a way that I can
solve it and charge for it that's it
like that's really all that business is
and really how well you solve the
problem is going to dictate how much
virality your business has because if
you solve it really well people will
tell people and your your business will
grow right I think the problem that a
lot of people have is they didn't know
how to make an offer right it's a
fundamental thing that is the beginning
of building a business is you got to
know what you're selling and so that was
a problem for a lot of people and then
people got that problem solved and then
they told their friends and books on 100
000 copies in six months with no
promotion and so I'm only I'm sharing
this because I couldn't write a book on
offers without having made a ton of
offers and I feel like there's two often
people who are trying to focus on a
niche who've never actually done the
thing in the niche and this is really
really rampant in the Internet space
because everyone's trying to take a
shortcut to get there when they realize
like what I'm telling you right now
you're never going to get there because
you're not good enough like you're never
gonna get there because you're not good
enough you have to do the Rocky cutscene
you have to eat four period of time so
that you can get the Reps in so you can
put your time under the bar in so that
you can actually get good and before you
are good you will suck and you have to
accept long period of sucking and you do
enough volume that eventually you'll
suck so little that you'll actually be
good and then at that point then you'll
actually have a real decision to make
which is I'm actually really good at
this thing now that I've learned do I
want to teach it to other people or I
just want to do more of the thing that
I'm doing right because like a real
story can then just grow a team of 100
Realtors and own the entire thing which
is what I'd recommend this guy do right
rather than have an agency um that
doesn't right and so this is kind of
where where I think the problem is is
that like I had another question that
was sent to me on Instagram which is
like Hey how do I soft churn because a
lot of my a lot of my clients are
getting results and I'm like well duh
he's like I know he said he said how do
I sell from 10 000 to 100 000 a month
when I don't have a lot of testimonials
I was like
you're not good at the thing that you're
supposed to be good at it's why you
don't have testimonials that's why
you're not going 100 000 a month like
he's making the goal a hundred thousand
dollars a month rather than being good
I I I have no words I have no words I
don't get it you know what I mean like
everyone's in such a Rush that
you will never get there it is the
slowest path to getting there is to fool
yourself and thinking that you're good
something that you're not you have to go
and pull the thread and say which and
the thing is it's like well do what
you're passionate about whatever you're
not gonna be passionate about stuff that
you suck at what you have to do is like
which of these opportunities seem like
they have potentially have high leverage
and I'm going to learn from the bottom
right it's like one of the best ways to
learn stuff is starting at the bottom
not because because it's the only option
but because if you understand the entire
pathway of of a client Journey or of an
industry Journey then you will have more
trench knowledge more depth of
experience that you will be then able to
apply people see my you know videos on
Personal Finance people see videos of
mine on sales people's videos online
recruiting people see videos of mine of
marketing and it's like how did you
acquire all these skills it's because
like it's not like because I tried to
jump to the spot that I'm at you can't
skip like there's a sequence buildings
are built with foundations and your
career is a pyramid and the peak of that
pyramid is based on on the depth of the
foundation that you build and so like
I've said this before and I'll say it
again but your work works on you more
than you work on it and so even though
you might not be getting paid in the
period that you're at just because
you're struggling doesn't mean you're
failing and it means and the thing is as
long as you're getting better you're
making progress and the progress is the
success is that you are getting better
and like you will turn the corner like
that's an inevitability if you put
enough time in rule number three know
the problem there are a lot of different
things that come up in the business
world where I will see people conflate
or mistake what thing they are solving
right and most times when I'm talking to
a newer entrepreneur or even a more
established entrepreneur and they reach
out for help or guidance or whatever
right or it's one of our portfolio
companies most times they'll start
talking right really fast about all this
stuff to try and provide context and
I'll just usually pause them and be like
what problem are we solving it usually
gets them to stop right and I would I
would highly advise you if you're if
you're dealing with if you have
subordinates or you have direct reports
uh who roll into you and they have a
whole bunch of decisions a lot of times
it can get caught and sometimes
ourselves too we can get caught in the
in the day-to-day the minutia and just
simply pause and say what problem are we
solving there's so many pieces of this
that I want to unpack that I think are
going to be really interesting for you
but the first one is when you define
what problems you are solving you may
even have to ask the question is that a
problem when some people are like well
hey we're getting you know customer
service complaints it's like okay
understood
is this something that we believe that
we can reasonably eliminate is this
something that is catastrophic to the
business or is this something that we
can kind of try and improve over time
you know through systems and process
right and so a lot of times people
misprioritize problems because they
perceive them as as threats to existence
when in reality they are a course of
doing business and things that be can
constantly improve right especially if
you're newer you're starting out of
course your product's not going to be
perfect yet right you're just getting
going
but you improve these things rather than
thinking I have to stop everything to
fix this problem right and so the first
frame shift is that most people think in
terms of like I have a problem to solve
rather than a dichotomy to be managed as
in these are two things that will always
exist all right I'll give you a
different example of this
um actually this will be a fun one the
reason we will probably never have
people who are all happy about a tax
code is because you cannot have both
fairness and equality equality means
everyone pays 10 percent fairness means
the rich people pay more than the poor
people that's fair this is equal both
are ideals and yet somehow they're not
the same thing and yet both are right
and so because of that we will always
have this conflict it's the same thing
between Justice and mercy both of them
are ideals both of them are right and
yet somehow they're conflicting and so
we we see these situations and this is
why I'm trying to hopefully give this to
you because the more I started to
recognize these patterns the more
quickly I can recognize them and then
identify by them and then either dismiss
them or say oh it's another one of those
right it's a pattern recognition it's
like oh you guys are spending all this
effort trying to solve a problem that is
unsolvable this is a dichotomy that must
be managed and will never be eliminated
and so I think what my goal with this
video is if I can help you get out of
these little mental hamster wheels uh
it's been incredibly valuable for me all
right so that's the dichotomy that's
like one of the one of the things that
people will mistake they'll mistake a
dichotomy for a problem that needs to be
solved all right another framework
um that that I find immensely valuable
is the concept of of a Continuum versus
a binary all right this is probably one
of the biggest mental errors that people
make when they're trying to identify
things and this is what I mean by that
so for example I might say I'll use a
weight loss example so people will say
something like uh I am off my diet or
I'm on my diet right it's a very simple
thing and that's because psychologically
we like to be binary we like to label
things as yes or no but biology and
reality exist on continuums as in to
what extent did you go off of your diet
right did you go 200 calories average
you go 500 calories over and as even
though it is quote more difficult to
think in this way it is also more
accurate and so our brain uses binaries
as placeholders for decision making to
store data right when in reality when
you start storing all these binary
decisions they start adding up and you
start getting more and more unaccurate
if that's a word on your decision-making
process because you're actually basing
your decisions not on facts but based on
binary shorthand that your brain saves
and so that is one of the biggest
mistakes that I see all the time in
thinking in entrepreneurs and really in
anything in general because we like to
have that shorthand it is easier right
it's easier to say I fell off my diet or
I am diabetic when the reality is it's
not whether you are a diabetic it's how
diabetic are you right kind of
interesting I stole that from Dr cashi
but I just love that who's my closest
friend he's a biochemist and we talk
about this stuff all the time point
being if you can think about this within
I'll give you I'll give you a business
example so if we have a a binary where
people are saying yes or no which is
let's say Facebook doesn't work
marketing doesn't work I hear these
statements all the time and you may
laugh at this right but I get DMs like
this all the time Facebook doesn't work
for me marketing doesn't work for me
like you can't sell this way in my
business right and so people want to
shorten a problem into yes it works no
it doesn't work when so much of business
and problem solving is understanding the
Nuance between where we're starting and
where we're going and it's to what
extent
has Facebook not worked right where is
the fall off right it is not that it
doesn't work it is just we only got it
to work this percent right now we need
to get all the way over the hump to get
there but it's to what extent and I
think that when I when if you if you can
ask the right questions if you can see
the problems as they truly are they
become far more solvable and so this has
been probably I just gave you two of my
my best frames that I think with all the
time all right so I'll say these again
so the first uh mental lapse I'll say
that I see all the time
is mistaking a dichotomy that needs to
be managed for a problem that needs to
be solved people do this in their
marriages as well right so you look at
your wife right you look at your wife
and you're like I need more variety
right but later you're like I need more
consistency and you're like we have to
figure this out we need variety we need
consistency it's like yes you need both
right and so it's not a problem to be
solved it's a dichotomy to be managed
rule number four start simple in a
perfect world if everyone had absolute
information and everyone was
unbelievably well trained and you had a
great infrastructure and all that stuff
then yes the more products and services
you offer in theory you would make more
money but we don't live in that
theoretical world most of the time and
most small business owners are not that
good at operating right it's the number
one issue they have they're super
disorganized they feel like they're
spinning the reels all day their team
completely has no idea what which way
they're going they change things all the
time Etc and so in an effort to combat
that we have used this process over and
over again and it has worked very well
so it is as follows we sell two things
and I've done this in virtually every
business that I've ever owned we sell
two things two products or two services
and this is once we're going from one to
ten million all right zero to one
million you sell one product or one
service one Avatar all right that's it
one channel one product one Avatar
that's it right but once you're going
from one to you know one to three ish
million and you're trying to go to ten
you introduced the second product line
and so here's how this works if you have
two things that you sell you'll have a
front-end thing and you'll have a
back-end thing we can still have a a
massive accommodation in the buying
curve based on the payment terms that we
introduce so for example people will
look at their monthly expense more than
the total contract value that's a huge
money hack I'm giving you right now this
is a wealth hack this is something that
will build make you a fortune in your
life if you can properly understand this
people do not look at the length or the
total contract they're signing they will
only pay attention to what is it going
to cost me every month because no one is
good with their money all right so they
only look at the cash flow expense month
over month over month and they just
think can I make it happen yes cool I'll
sign they don't think about the total
contract value for you as a business
owner the contract value matters almost
more than anything so I'll give you a
quick hack on this total side note
tangent for you life hack Pro tip if you
want to extend the contract value that
you have I have a sag which is the
bigger the head the longer the tail all
right and so what that means is the more
you can get someone to pay up front and
relative to The Upfront cost of signing
up or what they paid down
the lower their contractual recurring
payment is the stickier it will be so
I'll give you an example if I had
someone sign up for 99 a month for
whatever it doesn't matter that price
point might be medium sticky depending
on the value that I have now imagine I
had someone pay five thousand dollars
down and 99 a month after that how much
more sticky would it be significantly
more sticky now the beauty is if you
have one of these upfront type payments
you can also use that to liquidate your
ad cost cover your commissions for the
salesperson cover The Upfront
fulfillment and onboarding which is
going to cost more for a new customer
than an existing customer and so you can
build all that in if you know that the
thing that you are selling has very high
gross margins then you can still have a
lower cost as long as you know that the
person is going to stay for a long time
and So based on how you structure the
pricing you can actually get some you
can use the pricing to actually get
people to stick longer Pro tip complete
that is it moving back to the original
thing that I was talking about in one of
our portfolio companies we actually had
this as a really in-depth discussion
that we had to make a decision about all
right and so they had a different you
know Mentor person whatever advice uh
who told them that they should have
three products and they should have uh
you know low a medium and a high product
and then based on uh you know what the
salesman thought the salesman would sell
them the low medium or high in my
experience it is not that effective and
that is because the sales person can't
decide which of these things they are
trying to sell most of the time and so
what we have found is more effective is
you give the salesperson the one dream
to sell this thing is going to solve
this person's problem and we make it the
most valuable thing that we're trying to
sell because at the end of the day you
do want to solve the the customer's
problem right we do want to actually
make sure that we're providing value
rather than having a diet a medium and a
great right Simply Having one thing that
solves all the problems and then based
on the the customer's budget we can
decrease how they pay all right so hear
me out so let's say that uh we want to
do a uh this is a six month
implementation of whatever kind of
solution you sell if you have a six
month duration you can have the person a
pay the entire thing up front so that
would be for somebody who has the
highest budget version two would be a
split pay version three might be three
payments right with at twenty percent
higher and then finally you might have a
have a have a you know a six pack or
whatever over that period of time so one
two three six now here's the cool thing
the more payment options you provide the
higher your conversions are that's
proven all right so the more options you
give someone to pay the more people will
buy
period now you might not make more cash
flow because if you give your sales guy
more options than they might use they'll
end up defaulting to the lower ones
right but if you have one thing to sell
then they only have one thing to
convince the person of because a
confused money doesn't buy if you have
too many options the salesman won't know
what to sell and the prospect won't know
what to buy and so I prefer when I'm
coming into a portfolio company I'm
thinking what is this true problem that
we are solving with this business for
what Avatar and we make that the main
thing and we communicate it clearly in
the scripting and the salesperson has
Clarity on what they are selling and
they're always solving the same thing
and so the question becomes no longer
which of these things are you going to
buy but once you are buying how would
you like to pay and so then the
discussion is around what payment plan
is best for them rather than what
product is best for them and so by doing
that you can get people to go between
different payment terms that is not
going to change whether they're going to
buy but if they're unsure about which
product is going to best suit their
needs and the salesman doesn't know
because at the end of the day he's just
trying to sell the most expensive thing
then you'll have way more confused
people who leave unsold so this is a
single tactic that you can use to
execute within your business which is
why I'm a big fan of making offers
people cannot say no to is that you can
focus all of your sales and all of your
persuasion attempts on selling the one
thing which is getting them to say yes
once they say yes we can we can reach
the we can accommodate their wealth and
their budget based on the payment terms
that we provide and if we have done we
have structured our offer properly the
offer in and of itself should already be
very high gross margins which means
whether or not the person pays a
thousand dollars a month or a hundred
dollars a month it's still almost all a
margin for us because of how we
structure the thing that we are selling
and so we are able to capture Higher
ltvs by getting the people who have more
money to prepay the thing up front that
is how we do it and with those people
you'll be able to ascend into the second
thing faster because they've already
prepaid that thing and then you can
solve the next natural problem in
another sales conversation rather than
trying to pick all of the things in one
conversation which makes it incredibly
difficult to do this is just for
everyone again a broad brush stroke of
statements for most entrepreneurs who
are not very good at operating their
businesses uh her operations is not
their strong suit and are below three
million dollars a year
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free work
the worksheet will highlight all the
Lessons Learned in this video as well as
pull out our three favorite learnings
and quotes that will inspire you to
actually do something the worksheet will
also give you space to write down what
your key takeaways are and your specific
plan of action to make sure you're
getting results if you want the
worksheet design specifically for this
video absolutely for free there's a link
in the description below go click on it
and start building the momentum in your
life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five ask the right
questions I say this because all of us
right I do this I do this all the time
right and this is going to be repeated
theme because it needs to be repeated
right we need to be reminded more than
we need to be taught that is a saying
that we have in my world and I will I
will pass it on to you guys Mosey Nation
we need to be reminded more than we need
to be taught do the boring work repeat
successful actions and so
if he's gotten to this point or if
you've gotten to a point in your
business and it has plateaued the
question is has it plateaued because
this is true like I have the only reason
a business should Plateau that is
reasonable that is not your fault is
that you have reached the total
addressable Market as in you have
saturated the total the total Market of
that thing so for example if you were
selling dog food and every dog within
this you know maybe you saw a specific
type of niche of poodle food right
you've gotten you know 70 of poodle
owners to buy your food and you can't
grow anymore beyond that right well that
would be reasonable but then you'd
obviously just do a different type of
dog right you'd you'd hop verticals
right so there's not even a reason but
it would be the only potentially
rational reason
um would be uh that your Market uh has
changed so a different examples a friend
of mine owns a company that does uh
newspaper advertising right so they
actually help newspapers translate their
advertisements into digital products
which is pretty cool so they are able to
sell a whole like basically a whole new
ad product to small businesses um who
want to buy ads right which is by the
way how newspapers make money he could
not grow his business because newspapers
have shrunk by 25 year over year which
is 25 compounding the wrong direction
and he's been in that business for like
10 years so now the market size is like
literally like five percent of what it
used to be 10 years ago and so as a
result of that he was growing at an
inverse rate to the shrinkage of the
industry right and so he got to a point
where he couldn't grow anymore than just
basically servicing the ones that are
still alive and then as they fell so did
his business right and so that is the
only logical reason that a business can
Plateau that is not in your control and
unless you're selling your newspapers
which are probably not the reason is
much simpler which is you just don't
know how and I'll tell you a different
story that I had and then I'll I'll I'll
wrap this up at the end so I was having
a different conversation with a woman
who is doing I think four million
dollars a year and she was selling uh
info products that were weight loss like
weight loss info products so like
programs and ebooks and things like that
which is cool right she's a big
following all that kind of stuff and we
got I went I did a podcast with her and
uh after we got off the podcast she was
like yeah so these are my plans I'm
going to be doing like an apparel line
and a supplement line and uh cream line
and whatever right and I just kind of
sat there and I was like well I think
that's a terrible idea she was like she
just looked at me across there she's
like what I was like yeah I think it's a
terrible idea and she was like oh and I
was like why don't you just take the
thing that's making you four million
dollars and make it make you 10 million
dollars
when you do that
and the and the answer is the same as
the first answer I just don't know how
and I was like right well why don't we
solve that problem
and then not create a new business why
don't we just put all of our effort in
solving that problem and so I'm a big
believer and this is the the piece that
I want to share with you mosination is
that I'm a big believer in the theory of
constraints which means that a system
will grow until it is constrained right
it has a constraint and then once you
remove the constraint it'll continue to
grow right until it reaches another
constraint and so
most people are always curious are many
people ask me hey Alex how did you
achieve quote so much in quote such
little time or at such a young age and I
say all that in quotes because so much
could be and young age whatever but I'm
saying I'm just I'm paraphrasing all
right and I think that
um one of the things that we have done
well is prioritizing what problems to
solve
and that is understanding the
prioritization of problems and realizing
that there is really only typically one
or two things that are constraining our
growth and by definition there'd really
only be one thing that's the constraint
until we reach another thing that might
be beginning to constrain us but isn't
the true constraint yet number six have
the smarts and the hearts what it was
was setting the tone and the reason that
my views on business have dramatically
shifted is that I have always had a
tendency to lean towards strategy
acquisition monetization pricing
structures and all of that stuff is
important but I think within a business
there are two components to it you've
got the smarts and you've got the hearts
and you have to have both and I think
that most people overestimate the
importance of smarts myself included and
I think that there's a lot to do with
the hearts because this is strategy
overarchingly is not that complex like
you really think about it right it's
like you got to find something that's
good that people want and you sell it
for a lot more than it costs you to do
it and you do as much of that as you
possibly can like that's kind of the
idea right and the thing is is
it gets lost in the execution it get
lost in the doing right as soon as you
hire first employees you're like no
employees can't employees can't do what
I can do it's like well that's a
horrible belief you should probably
change that before we try and move
forward that's a limiting belief right
if you want to have a big business and
so when I think about this from a
cultural standpoint and this is what has
shifted for me is that it's become so
much more about the soft skills it's so
much more about coaching and developing
the leaders of the company it's it's so
much more about addressing behavioral
dynamics of someone that are limiting
them more so than it is about tinkering
and I can't help but think that so many
entrepreneurs myself included I spent so
much time tinkering and and tweaking
things what if we change this in our
sales process what if we change this on
this page what if we change the offer
like this what do we change this on the
price what if another payment terms blah
blah all these different things right
and think about this for a second for
yourself how many things have you
tinkered with in your business over the
last however many years how many months
and your business hasn't changed at all
right
because the real problem is not the
strategy the problem is not the smarts
right the problem is the heart right the
people are not doing what you want them
to do because they don't understand why
they need to do it and why it's
important right and that's the soft
stuff and you've got you know people who
don't want to talk to each other because
they don't like each other because one
guy's really annoying and so it's like
it would be it would better serve you to
fix that problem than to try and come up
with some new strategy right realizing
that has been one of the biggest
breakthroughs that I've had in my career
those two stories should illustrate the
difference between
um having a championship mentality and
having a loser mentality and what might
be going on in your business and I'll
leave you with one more story really
quickly so if any of you has ever
been on a championship team right if
you've ever played in a sports uh Arena
or whatever and you've been on a winning
team you've been on losing team right
and you've probably been on a losing
been a lot of good players but you guys
were not connected you weren't concerted
you weren't aligned right on the flip
side you had a winning team and it was
like everyone should have to practice
everyone you know tried their hardest it
was the effort and the consistency and
the alignment of the team that
accomplished the goal the rules were the
same everyone was trying to do the exact
same thing and so when you think about
the entire business landscape right your
competitors have access more or less to
the same talent pool that you do they
can see what your strategy is overall
and most people are not that dumb right
and so as long as you have a relatively
sound strategy like you're not selling
things at a loss right then the
difference between the two is going to
be your ability to execute and have
people execute on your behalf and so
that's going to become that like for us
as CEOs we do shift towards becoming
championship team coaches which is why
John wouldn't if he had run a business
would have had a championship business
because he focused on the fundamentals
and one of my favorite sayings of all
time is Advanced people never don't do
the basics Advanced people never don't
do the basics I would go to I would go
to these stages and I would watch guys
get on stage and they'd say you know we
we follow up with all of our leads you
know within five minutes you know when
we get on sales calls we always ask them
why they're there we label them a
problem you know we overview some of the
past things they've done and then they
they follow a clear framework that as
soon as someone buys we you know we have
a good onboarding process and nothing
they say is revolutionary it's just that
they actually do it and the people are
actually on their behalf they're not the
Vince or don't have a manager like Vince
who's telling them they don't that they
shouldn't have to do that work right
who's sabotaging the business what they
did is they set the tone and then they
carry the bar and so their job is to be
intolerant of anything but excellence
and to reinforce that in the culture so
that it's consistently executed across
the company because that between two
companies with the same strategy will
make the difference between somebody who
who yields disproportional Returns on
Advertising crazy profits good growth
great retention on employees low
turnover from a company that doesn't
have that right even though they both
have the same strategy or even if the
smaller company has the better strategy
this guy will win and this has been one
of the most profound shifts that I've
had rule number seven find the right
partner if you're just starting out I
think that for the most part it's better
to not have partners and that is because
usually it's like you and a buddy and
you're like hey we like hanging out we
should go into business together when
really you're doing that for the
emotional need to be satisfied to have
somebody to talk to and share the
experience with but not because it's a
good business decision and the only
reason for you to have a partner is
because they either have money or skills
that you do not have that is it it's the
only reason money or skills that's it
and so if you both are entrepreneurial
people and you're both you know love
selling you love marketing you're very
promotion oriented which many
entrepreneurs are right if that's you
then if they're that way too then one of
you is not required and you have to
really face that so if you both like the
same stuff you both shouldn't be in
businesses and just talk about being
about your own specific businesses but
not team up together it almost always
fails like literally it almost always
fails and so that's the first one the
second thing is that those jump into bed
to be other Partnerships don't have step
number two which is you don't have a
contract you don't have terms you don't
have an agreement and the reason is
because you're so afraid of like messing
up the vibe we don't operate that way
you will when it gets up at the
end but I'm telling you right now I I
now even when I have somebody who
approaches me and says hey like will you
take a percentage of my company can you
coach me through this blah blah I say
let's go through the lawyers first all
right because the thing is is you get to
see how this person acts under stress
because it is stressful because
inherently you're going to disagree on
things and so this is the perfect
experience like perfect time for you to
go kind of get a simulation of that well
it's like well what happens if you don't
want to work and I want to work what
happens if you leave what happens if I I
don't want to do this anymore well like
you have to go through all the scenarios
and get a good lawyer and you should
really have two that represent you uh if
you don't have the money for that then
get somebody to just counsel you on you
know you can Google a standard
partnership agreement their templates
for free online and you can pay one
lawyer for one hour of of time to at
least say these are the things you
should look for now you know decide
amongst yourselves and so you can
represent yourself in your partnership
you know agreement but you have to have
the agreement and you have to spell it
out in clear terms uh because if you
don't have that it's like it's the
Bedrock of good communication and
expectations right like otherwise
usually like most relationships
Partnerships end because of unmet and
unspoken expectations like well I
thought you're gonna do this I was like
well I didn't know but no one even says
that because it can't communicate so
first is you probably shouldn't just
jump together with somebody because they
uh they're just like you
if you are going to do that then you
should make sure that you have contracts
in place and then finally what I want to
do is kind of explain to you what the
three main roles roles that exist in a
business are okay three the three
pillars all right I want to see if I
have a tripod here all right here we go
here's my tripod all right so there's
three pillars
to every business all right the first is
acquisition which is The Rainmaker or
somebody who's gonna bring in business
so that's marketing and sales all right
acquisition the money getter all right
the second of these is the product which
is what you are actually selling it's
the Fulfillment it's the service it's
the widget it's the whatever somebody
who knows how to deliver it all right
and then third
you have the operations which is
everything else that has to happen in
the company paying payroll paying taxes
making sure legal and contracts and I.T
and uh you know finance and all like the
uh you know you're accounting all of
that stuff HR has to happen right and so
these are the three legs of every
business now they're not necessarily
equally weighted and that's it's an
important point right like a lot of
times there are good operators that you
can get for significantly less and many
times not even Equity
um because there are more of them right
now rainmaking being able to bring in
business is a very highly valued skill
in the marketplace on the flip side
having the thing the product that you're
going to sell is also very valuable now
this is why skill stacking is so
important if you can have multiple of
these skills then you have two or all
three of the legs right now your these
are the roles that have to exist it
doesn't mean you have to be partners
with these people but you have to have
all three of these things for your
business to stand up and so for example
within uh the company I'll walk you
through my roles within each of the
companies that I own
and so uh the first is gym launch right
so in gym launch I am both the
acquisition and the product right or
that was my founding role within the
company Layla my wife runs ran all the
operations so everything else so like I
said it billing legal uh Finance HR all
of that stuff that had happened she took
care of right super important but
because of that we had all three legs of
the stool and we were able to build a
business right if you're missing one of
the legs it's not going to work right if
and with this is where this is really
dangerous is like a lot of the marketing
people that are in this world are really
good promoters they can get people in
they can sell them but then they have no
fulfillment they have no thing right and
then they have no one who's organized
and so everything like you send emails
in you try and get help and they don't
respond it's because they just don't
have the other pieces I don't think it's
because they're bad intentioned I think
just don't have the skill and so you
have to have all three and so if you're
going to bring someone in
you you need them to have one of those
things right now you can start a
business and own all of it and just make
sure that you fill the roles of those
people but as you're thinking through it
there's the rule so if you're going to
bring Partners in in the beginning you
want to be clear about what it is that
they're bringing to the table now if
they're if they're one of those three
right then that's a clearly defined role
and then at that point that's what you
can lay out in your agreement and then
you can argue about or you know
negotiate whatever Equity if you're
doing this in the beginning but if
you've already started at that point
then you can look at the three legs of
the stool and see where where am I
lacking right and so for most of you
guys who are listening most people
follow me are on the or like the
promotion side so they like the
acquisition side
then what you need to do is find a
strong operator all right and depending
on what you're selling if you know the
thing that you're selling then you can
basically be product and acquisition and
have a strong second to help you fulfill
on those things and basically don't go
to jail right and you know get file your
taxes and all the other stuff
um and so when I'm thinking about
Partnerships and when I have you know
younger guys who are coming in many many
times after having discussions with me
and then talking to them each other they
realize that they had the exact same
role they like the same things and one
of them is not necessary and so they
oftentimes split and that's not a bad
thing right it's better to recognize an
error early than to recognize an error
late all right and so you may be in one
of these Partnerships where you're like
we gotta both do the same thing we kind
of just overlap on everything it's like
yeah that's just two people working the
same thing
um and so it's not like you don't want
to just be like oh there here's all this
work I'll do half you do have that's not
a good partnership you have to figure
out what are the things where I am good
at what are the things you are good at
and then we draw a line on the board and
everything on that side you own
and everything on this side I own and
I'm responsible for because if
everyone's responsible for everything no
one's responsible for anything right and
then nothing's going to get done and
then you can never know who to blame and
someday you're like well he takes out
the trash or sometimes I take out the
trash and we just kind of we're just
like kind of get it done type of stupid
there's no there's no big business that
works that way all right and so if even
if you are small you need to start
thinking big to become big right so you
got to do the actions before you get the
results you have to have the beliefs
before you get the outcomes of a bigger
business to become a bigger business and
the reason most businesses stay small is
because they think small and they act
small so they stay that way because the
outcome of what they're doing is the
result of the actions they're making
which are small right and so right now
if you're in a partnership
if you don't have a partnership you're
thinking about starting a business
I would definitely try and just acquire
the skills myself
get going and then the first hire I'm
going to have is going to be a strong
operational second right it's the first
thing I'm going to do if you are in a
partnership you need to put all the
activities that you do on a board I do
this when I do consulting stuff but all
the activities that happen in the
business on the board if you don't know
what it is you do a Time study which
means you write down every 15 minutes
what you do in a week right because you
probably don't know because you
scattered all over the place so if you
write it on down and you both bring it
to each other and you put it on a
whiteboard or put it on board then what
you can do is say okay these are all the
things these are all the activities that
happen in our business
let's divide these out and say who owns
these all right and that's the very
beginning of an organization because you
are becoming organized you're
creating roles and responsibilities
you're creating specialization of skills
which is what moves Humanity forward
specialization is a good thing right and
so the very beginning you get all of it
on there and you can divide it out and
you can divide it based on the skills of
the person if you both have the same
skills then either need to decide okay
well I'm going to become a specialist in
this and you're going to become a
specialist in this or we shouldn't be
doing this business together and you
should do a business that's just like
mine or or something else and you should
become and you should be that role for
that company and you should find a
second just like Iowa all right and
oftentimes if you can at least think
that way then you don't lose you don't
liquidate the most valuable thing in the
whole world which is your Equity all
right because if your thing actually
does grow if your business actually does
grow
then the biggest dilution of how much
money you're going to make is that first
decision when you started when you just
decided just right off the bat to give
half of everything away rule number
eight build the passive income first off
I'm a big believer in continuing to take
dividends out of a business as it
continues to grow and that's because you
want to decrease your downside risk
right because for some reason and the
statistics are very likely that the
business will not succeed in the long
term you know 90 whatever it is 90 or 95
of businesses fail within five years and
so uh it's it's much better in my
opinion to consistently take money out
of the business as you're growing it
because there's a very high likelihood
that it will not stick around A and B
many entrepreneurs have this idea that
they're going to sell their business for
some magical number sometime in the
future when in reality only one percent
of businesses ever sell and so if that
is the case again well I would rather
not stack the chips on a 91 to one bet
it does happen but the likelihood is low
and so I would like to take chips off
the table table on a regular basis so
that is the first part which is making
sure that we're taking money out the
second question is okay well now that I
have this 18 is 500 this million this
whatever what should I do with it right
and so one of the big things is I just
like to think about this through the
lens of opportunity cost which is if I'm
currently making let's say uh 500 000 a
year right from my business in in every
cash flow that's owner earnings what I
get to take out of the business after
reinvesting in in the growth and
competitive advantage that we need to
continue to maintain to to grow right so
if I have 500 000 of net free cash flow
that's coming to me and let's say I've
got a million dollars saved up if I were
to if I were to passively invest that I
should get about 10 ish a year right
that's just going to be investing
through uh indexes like the S P 500 Etc
right if I'm doing that then the
advantage of actively investing might be
the marginal difference it might be an
extra five or ten percent so that'd be a
50 to 100 increase because 10 to 15 is a
50 increase right but if I look at it in
terms of real terms uh just purely on
how much my net worth is going to
increase which is the lens that we have
to look at this through which is the
opportunity cost if I were to spend half
of my time thinking about actively
investing because it will take up half
your your mind space I promise you
because I've done this mistake before I
made this mistake before then what
happens is your active income will fall
at a disproportionate rate compared to
what uh your money is making you so let
me I'll walk you through a numbers
example so let's say you've got that
million dollars and you can get 10 a
year which is 100 Grand on 100 possible
Right but the additional 50 or 100 000 a
year uh fifty to a hundred thousand
dollars a year which would be five to
ten percent of that million right you
could get through actively investing
well if you're currently making 500 000
a year from your business do you think
it would be reasonable to take half or
25 of your time to go chase that when
you could probably get your income from
500 to 750 000 in the next year 500 to a
million and so for me that was always
the opportunity cost of actively
investing which until my wealth became
so large that I felt like it was out the
opportunity cost of the money that I
should be making by paying more
attention to my money was going to out
piece my income which is still almost
not there and so for me that is why as
for entrepreneurs it's my belief that a
you should be ripping out cash on a
regular basis because that's downside
risk protection it's not your upside it
is downside protection it's the fact
that what if my business does not
succeed as much as I'm I'm a big
believer in being optimistic you also
have to face reality and confront facts
which is the likelihood that this
particular business that you're on I've
had 13 businesses that I've started up
to this point and now I own eight more
the likelihood that the business that
you start is going to be the one that
you finish with is extremely extremely
extremely low right extremely low and
the likely that you're going to sell
that business for a big number is
extremely extremely extremely low and so
you take this money out and you put it
into the s p or you put it into an index
because it is passive and you can put it
there and the idea is that you never
have to think about it again now the
amount of money that you should keep in
cash uh in in my belief is you should
have a six months two years worth of
normal living that's saved up in cash
and that's just so that you can sleep
well at night and that's it the other
thing is that when you invest that into
indexes and whatnot you can always alone
against those assets if you wanted to
start something big so it's not like
it's illiquid when it's there you can
take loans against those assets at 60 or
70 percent uh loan to value meaning if
you have a million dollars in assets uh
in the s p most banks will give you 60
70 of that uh or at least 50 right
depending on the stocks in in your
history with them Etc that will give you
basically for free right they'll give
you that one percent or two percent uh
money that you can go and reinvest in
starting another business or buy a piece
of real estate or whatever right and so
for entrepreneurs it is my belief that
you should be investing most of your
time and energy or almost 100 of your
time and energy and growing your income
growing the main vehicle you have but
extracting the money and putting it into
a low brain vehicle that's not active
that's passive that's truly passive not
real estate flipping that's not passive
right truly passive if you're in crypto
right or you have some speculative stuff
that you that you want to get into it's
probably taking up way more of your
attention than it should be and it's
actually going to make your main income
suffer which means your net worth will
grow more slowly than otherwise would so
it's all about the opportunity cost of
your attention all right now I'm going
to put this special note out here for
employees if the the primary objective
of the employee in my opinion is to
increase how much your income is and so
all of yours and this goes for
entrepreneurs too the the initial parts
of your investment should be growing to
increase your skills because that
increases your basis that increases your
basic income that you can continue to
yield from the marketplace based on your
skill set and so this is where I think
people step you know they step out over
dollars to pick up pennies if you're
saving you know 500 a month there's
nothing wrong with that but I would be
actively investing at 500 or the
Thousand or two thousand dollars a month
in the beginning into making my skills
more valuable because I know that if I
do that in two years I might quadruple
my income because that's the thing is
that your ability to earn is one of the
greatest Investments that's not just a a
billionaire saying it really is like you
can like if you develop the skill of
selling which might take you two years
you can go from making sixty thousand
dollars a year to two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year or five hundred
thousand dollars a year which puts you
in the tops one percent just by earning
that one skill and so if you can develop
that skill it is worth the investment in
most investments in self-improvement are
so disproportionately low that it is
worth the investment even if there are
courses that you only get a handful of
things from you are still as yourself an
asset more valuable at the end of the
day you are the source you're the source
of where all the money comes from so
it's like when people don't invest in
themselves it makes no sense to me I've
spent every dollar I possibly could
gaining access getting mentorship
getting coaching getting programs buying
courses buying books and and doing that
stuff because I'm the source right if I
can improve me as the machine that
generates all the flow of income then
the rest of the stuff becomes easy right
and so first and foremost you have to
invest in that after you have an excess
of that then start pulling the dividends
out of the business that you have
investing those things that are passive
not active and then at the point where
your net worth from your investable
assets what 10 of that net worth growth
would be is in excess of what you make
per year then at that point it makes
sense to start shifting your perspective
towards managing wealth and growing
wealth rather than growing income Rule
Number Nine stop limiting yourself a lot
of people struggle with this which is
they believe that they are inherently
bad at things because they are not good
at them
and I think that that is an incredibly
dangerous belief set to have and so what
I want to do is kind of break that
belief sit down to hopefully break it
for you so I think one of the most
valuable beliefs because you know in
terms of building on success in my
opinion first you need to develop skills
that need to develop character traits to
make sure that you do those skills and
then you have to make sure that your
beliefs are correct so that you can open
up the world right but the beliefs are
kind of imbued throughout the entire
process because if you don't believe you
can acquire a skill you never will right
if you don't believe you're gonna have a
character trait you never will and so
um I was having a conversation with a
friend of mine who's
um looking to you know switch career
paths you're trying to figure out she
wasn't making as much money she wanted
to make
and the issue
um that she was dealing with she was
like she just doesn't have a valuable
enough skill set right and she's like I
want to make this much money and I was
like well you're never going to do that
doing what you're doing right
um and I was like have you considered
learning how to sell right I mean
because if you sell you have a far you
know if you still have the desire for
security but if you know how to sell you
can you know pretty much write your own
paycheck if you know where to look and
um she was like I'm not I'm not good at
sales I'm not a sales person and I was
like well how many hours of sales
training have you gone through it was
like oh you know none and I was like
well then why would it be reasonable for
you to be good at sales
right like that doesn't that doesn't
make any sense of course you're not good
at sales like you haven't done it right
well it's so it's the same thing like
well I'm not a very marketing type
person I was like well how many courses
have you gone through how many hours a
day do you spend studying marketing well
you know none well then why is it
reasonable that you like why would it it
would be unreasonable for you to be good
at this skill given the amount of
investment you've made right and so it's
this it's this recurring thing that I've
seen over and over and over again
um and it also it presents itself in
different ways like I you know I'll
speak at some event or something and
I'll start getting into very basic math
about about business just business math
like you know how much does it cost to a
Car customer how much what's the
lifetime value things like that and I
can see people starting to freak out
because they're like I'm not good at
math
and I have to lean back and our lean you
know pressure onto that belief because
one that's a belief that will literally
never serve you it's like saying like I
hate employees it's like well good luck
owning a business that you want to grow
to any appreciable scale right
um but with the math example most you
can you can you can massively succeed in
business knowing only out like not even
algebra just basic multiplication
subtraction division like if you just
know how to do that that's all you need
to do and just about everyone knows how
to do those things and at the very least
has a calculator who can do
multiplication division at addition and
subtraction that's it that's all you
literally need and the thing is is that
people mistake
that they are bad at math
when in reality they do not understand
the concepts that create the math right
cost per acquisition right okay that's a
math statement just expressed in words
and so everyone gets tripped up and then
they say I'm bad at math when in reality
they just don't understand the term and
by doing that they inherently limit
themselves from learning because they
have this checkbox in their head that as
soon as it gets difficult they say ah
I'm bad at this I am bad at this I
identify with being poor at this thing
and therefore will never succeed at this
thing that's a requirement for being
successful
and so
I think that for me one of the
Cornerstone beliefs that I that that has
helped me a tremendous amount I just
want to share it with you is that
um if someone can therefore I can
and sure is that does that necessarily
mean that you're going to you know go to
the go to go to Mars it's like no one's
ever done that before I think that's the
next level belief no one's ever done it
and I'm gonna be the first right but I
think if you can at least just believe
that if someone has done it it is
therefore possible and therefore I can
do it too if I do the same things and
the nice thing about actions is that
they are agnostic to your level of
deservingness and skill
what I mean by that is if you spend an
hour a day practicing sales
over a year you will likely be in the
top
ten percent five percent two percent of
people because most people do nothing
most people do absolutely nothing except
for deal with their emotions on a
regular basis and procrastinate and give
themselves reason for why they are not
successful besides the obvious one which
is that it is not reasonable that they
would be successful given the amount of
time and effort they've put in to
achieving it and so
um I the only reason for this is because
I had that conversation I spoke at The
Mastermind where the girl talked about
uh not understanding the math
um I I and just there's just so many
repeated of you know events like this
where it's like can you ask yourself
with reason would it be reasonable for
me to be good at this skill given the
investment I've made and uh as a
corollary as an antithesis to that
example I've got an 18 year old kid who
lives across the street from me
um and I sort of you know semi-mentor
him
um he's a good kid he works super hard a
lot of hustle and the thing is is he's
too young to know that he can't do
things yet
and what that does is it makes them
incredibly dangerous because he hasn't
been slapped in the face by the world
yet and so he believes that he can
accomplish anything he has no reason to
think otherwise and so I've been
actively trying to speak that into him
um and now he's he's wholesaling real
estate right now he's 18 years old right
uh I love this right and how did he do
it he watched YouTube videos for free
right and then he picked up cold calling
because I was like this is a book you
need to read for cold calling and so he
just started cold calling based on what
the YouTube videos said off of a free
list that he found on the internet and
he closes for his deal as 18 year old
and so does he have an inherent skill no
but what I did was I prepared him
mentally by saying like you're going to
suck at this for a very very long time
and eventually after doing it so many
times it will be unreasonable for you to
suck and at that point you will be good
right and so I think if we can all
approach the skills that we feel like we
are deficient in with that kind of
concept of of course I am going to suck
it would not be reasonable for me to be
good
but if I do these actions it would over
time be unreasonable for me to be bad at
these things and I think by doing that
you unlock a different ability to learn
and by extension grow and so anyways I
hope you find this valuable uh it's just
it's a belief set that I find repeated
especially in people who are smaller
business owners who are getting started
Etc and it drives me nuts because it's
just saying that you can't do something
before you've even started and that's
why people spend so long in in the
beginner stage is because they they
inherently dispel away their ability to
learn and get better because say well
I'm not good at that well obviously
you're not good at that you have not
done it duh item number 10 the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
align with your authentic self I think
first off if you redefine the term from
happiness which is which is based on
outside circumstances you are happy as a
reaction Joy comes from within which
means that I can be sad and sorrowful
and filled with joy you can mourn and be
joyful because joyful is how you choose
to experience the circumstances so first
I would redefine the word that you're
shooting for right
um the second thing is is asking like
but why right and so a lot of us want to
make money because we're like I want to
you know and then and then when we talk
publicly it's like I want to leave a
legacy I want to leave an impact blah
blah blah blah right all that stuff I
want to help people but the reality is
that everything that you do that is
external achievement is ephemeral and
what it means is it literally only
exists on the physical plane and that
physical plane is temporary which means
it will end which means that all of the
achievements and all the things that
you're doing on this plane literally by
definition will have no lasting impact
and so if it means that nothing that you
do any all the things that you
accomplish and all the things or rather
the wealth that you accumulate will
eventually disappear it changes the
perspective somewhat and so the way that
I like to think about it is the analogy
of a casino and so I think all of us are
given a token when we're you know when
we come of age and start to get into the
game and we sit down at a table and we
play and we play and we play and we play
and the players around the table are
bragging about how they're how big their
chips are some players win when some
players lose and more more chips get
stacked right but the difference between
that casino and the casino of life is
that at the end of the day you leave the
table with your chips still on it and
you don't cash out and then everyone
takes the chips that you had there so
you're playing a fake game with fake
money
and so I think when you realize that
like you can buy a castle you can buy a
house and there's a person in India who
has no shoes who has more joy in their
life you realize that none of the things
that we do to accomplish
serve any real meaning whatsoever they
really just act as the shovel that we
use to dig the holes
that we're going to fill back up at the
end of the day when we die and so it's
like what shovel do you want to use to
dig your hole
and so I like to think of those things
as what things do I inherently find joy
in
and so for me I enjoy learning and I
learn through teaching and so that is
how I derive meaning and the only thing
that I can dedicate my life to that is
eternal are things that will last past
the physical plane which are values and
so if you can shift your decision making
process from outcome based decision
making process to value-based decision
making process you'll always feel in
alignment with your identity and so for
me when I experience alignment between
what I truly believe what I say and what
I do I feel like I'm acting in the way
that I that is in alignment with who I
am and so I think that a lot of us have
made decisions or say things that are
contrary to what we believe or we do
things that are contrary to what we say
we do things contrary to what we think
and we experience dissonance and that's
most of our lives and so I think that if
you can free yourself into thinking I
can I believe these things to be true I
say them with sir certainty and my life
is a reflection of those things which I
believe to be to be meaningful and I can
dedicate my life to that Eternal value
and that value will exist after I die
and so that for me is is is kind of
where I derive meaning
from work
we think that for some reason we are
doing something wrong when we are not
self-caring because it is bad too not
self-care because we should we must or
else or what and the reason this pisses
me off the reason that I made a tweet
that went viral um this morning about
this is that weekends are new for humans
they're not even 100 years old 1929 in
England is when the first weekend got
passed by a union and it's because
people hated what they were doing for
their life and so if you want to truly
give self-care then stop hating what you
do every day novel concept I know stop
hanging out with people that suck
mind-blowing like I said I know and the
reason that I am so passionate about
this is that I have been told throughout
my entire life that I was working too
much I was not balancing the things that
I was supposed to be balancing and you
know what who gives it's my life I don't
need to live by anyone else's rules and
neither do you right and so when people
say you should be doing this you are not
doing XYZ just take a pause and be like
are these rules that I want to listen to
are those your rules that you're trying
to apply to my life because there are no
rules you can do whatever the hell you
want if you want to work for a year
straight work for a year straight and
the reason you can work for a year
straight is because you like what you do
the reason these people try and project
their own self-hatred for their own
lives onto you is because they cannot
imagine a world in which someone might
actually like what they do every day and
didn't don't need an escape a break from
what their existence is on a daily basis
and so don't feel guilty for just being
you and if you don't like your life
every day rather than try and figure out
and make time for self-care it would
probably be better to flip the ratio and
start thinking what can I do in my
actual life to stop hating it so much
that I need an escape from it right and
that's different from like yes you need
to sleep yes you need to you know rest
Etc but there's a difference between
that and like I just need a total spa
day and if that's how you relax cool but
the thing is is projecting on someone
else how they should must need to have
to relax or do whatever it's nonsensical
it doesn't exist right I wanted to make
this video even though it's short
because I it just drives me bananas if
you want to work work if you want to
take off take off just don't listen to
what anyone else says about what you
should do for your life you're going to
die and so will they and it's not going
to matter and in 10 Generations don't
even remember your name so do what you
want you're going to die and that is the
ultimate freedom and for some reason we
live under these chains that we think
exists but don't and so I think the
process of of growing and really making
ourselves free is just simply
identifying the things that don't really
exist and only existed in our mind to
begin with and I think that's why
self-creator really bugs the out of
me or this whole self-care movement it's
also soft as like just work right
just get it done you need to like give
yourself a bubble bath every day because
like your work's so hard like humans
been here a very long time we've dealt
with much much harder your you know boss
having a deadline the next day is not
the worst that you've been through and
so as a final sign off on this think
about the hardest things that you've
been through in your life everyone has
gone through hardship everyone is had
difficulties in childhood everyone has
had difficulties with siblings with
parents blah blah blah these events that
shape Our Lives you have been through
harder than this you will survive it
will be okay you don't need to self-care
you don't need to listen to what anyone
else is saying you do you and if that
means self-care by all means just don't
protect anyone else most business
strategies are not complicated find
something that something find something
people want charge a lot of money for it
and deliver that thing really well so
much so that they tell other people
about your product it's not
overwhelmingly complex to consider the
execution is difficult but the concept
is not and so a lot of people think
they're going to win on strategy when
they're starting a business when you
could have two people who have lawn care
companies and one person has a long care
company worth a billion dollars one
person that can barely break five
thousand dollars a month it's not
because the strategy is significantly
different it's just the execution how is
it that an entrepreneur or two
entrepreneurs can start at the exact
same time and one can be get 10 20 30
times faster or when you start over
again you can always skip these steps to
get to your level of incompetence my
theory around this comes down to pattern
recognition and let me explain it's not
just pattern recognition from the
perspective that you have strategies are
something that you're you're recognizing
but actually patterns in people and so
I'm going to give this a quick story to
drive this this point home I have
struggled for the last decade to find an
assistant and so it's one of the things
I'm actually you know a little
embarrassed about but I I've gone over
seven on assistance
um so much sort of the point that I was
just I almost kind of gave up just even
trying to find an assistant and until
recently I every time I had an assistant
it just always right off the bat it just
never felt like right and I always was
like yeah maybe it'll get better it'll
get better at it and they just never
really did and the problem was that I
didn't know what it looks like when it's
right and so in the videos that I talk
about I use the word the term ideal
scene I don't know what the ideal scene
of this Dynamic looks like when we are
scared scaling companies right and I'll
tell you what I found out there in a
second but like when we're scaling
companies what we have to do is pay down
ignorance tax of knowing what ideal
scene looks like which is where speed
comes from having people who have
outside eyes look in who already do know
what I still ideal scene looks like so
you can skip steps faster and so I'll
give you an example what this looks like
in real life like for me in the role of
executive assistant thank God that like
for me it wasn't a necessary thing to
continue to grow the businesses now that
I have one I don't ever really want to
live life without one but
the entire time I kept bringing people
in I didn't know what to look for we do
hiring you know we do a hiring process
we do an onboarding and training process
they never really got up to speed or we
never really got in sync and then I'd
slowly kind of Fall Away there would be
distance and then it became kind of
awkward and then I would end up having
to cut the relationship and so in this
instance we immediately synced up I
really liked the person I trust the
person and they are so proactive in all
aspects of my life that I just sit down
and start working and then she places
things in front of me I'm like hey I got
13 minutes she's like cool do this I'm
like I've got you know 18 minutes here
she's like cool do this and do this and
every time I'm done I'm like hey what
else should I do and she's like boom and
so we meet based on the priorities that
I have and then she has this big stack
and knows how long every one of these
things takes because I talked to her
about how long I think the tax will take
and then as I have openings we slot it
in so it's like I wake up and I'm just
crushing work until the end of the day
because I know that the amount of time
that's been allotted for each the task
is the appropriate amount of time and so
and if I do finish early I get another
task done right and so we can we can we
can Crush stuff when I started in this
business I took every single sale and it
was because I was so afraid that
somebody would waste the opportunity so
if you have that fear I understand where
you're coming from second when I had my
first sale that was not me I I just had
this emotional breakdown because I was
like oh my God this could actually
happen and I promise you if you haven't
had it happen yet you will when it does
because you realize that this business
can actually work without you and other
people can make it rain too right and
then I'll tell you a quick story that
illustrate the next point then would
make so as I you know hired some sales
people now that first sales person were
they exceptional no but they were able
to get the job done later on I had my
first kind of like killer
um and his name was Mario negretti and
he uh he came in
I don't know a year or two into the
business a year into the business and he
so quickly was able to assume the sales
role and to show you how laughable this
is he started and I was about to start
training him and some lady walked in the
door and I was like hey man like I can
take he's like no I'm good he's like go
do your thing he's like Fitness
Nutrition accountability okay I'll
figure it out and he ended up closing
this first lady who walked in the door
for a paid in full and I remember
walking in like completely dumbstruck I
was like he didn't even know what the
pitch was but she walked out giggling
happy so excited to start and would that
moment taught me was that
it is good to train sales people but
it's better to take great sales people
and then just point them in a direction
and so this has informed a lot of the
thinking that I have Around Talent in
general and I'll tell you a couple of
Frameworks that have informed this but
like if you look at Harvard Harvard
doesn't produce the smartest people they
select the smartest people and then they
put smart uh professors in front of them
but like the base level of intelligence
of everyone who's at Harvard is already
exceptionally high and so like even if
the teachers at Harvard were not
exceptional the students are and they
would be successful independent of that
because their selection is so ridiculous
right and so if we can think about our
own companies that way and especially if
you're in the service business like look
at the biggest service companies out
there like look at McKinsey look at Bain
look at BCG look at basically a lot of
the finance world is or service-based
businesses a lot of times right and
they're able to do that because they
create such a pool to select from that
they are able to skim for the best
talent right I heard this uh quote from
uh es true Kathy who's the founder of
Chick-fil-A you win the championship in
the draft and so it was such a belief
that they had about picking the right
people even more so than training and I
would say that I have moved in that
direction of a little bit more nature
than nurture when it comes to roles
specifically sales especially there are
certain characteristics about building
Rapport about having certain you know
Dynamics or energy whatever you want to
say that like Mario negrady when he
walked in he had all of these things and
he didn't even know the pitch but he won
that sale off of Just Pure Rapport and
so if I'm going to allocate the same
level of time to training somebody I
might as well start with somebody who
has a much higher base because I could
spend 10 hours to take someone from a
two to a four and a half or I could
spend the same 10 hours taking someone
from a six to a nine and the thing is
I'm also going to get more bang for my
buck in terms of my hours of training
with somebody who has natched a natural
ability for selling compared to somebody
who does not what's interesting about
this and this is just like my
observation is that you just have to be
willing to talk to more people in the
recruiting process I will say like from
a recruiting standpoint there's there's
two kind of things to look out for if
you're if you're if you cannot pay super
handsomely based on your price points
which you need to maybe fix later but
like if you can't pay super well for the
sales person then you need to look
harder and you'll need to interview more
people and you'll need to probably run
ads and use your network if you can pay
well the best sales people are already
employed and so it comes down to
recruiting those sales people from other
sales jobs ideally from companies just
like yours so that they already know a
lot of the things coming into it so it
decreases the ramp up time for them
because all we were really doing is
swapping products and the actual sales
cycle the type of sale is it a
transactional sales at a long sales at a
software sales is it a coaching program
set whatever it is right there's so few
variables that were changing that they
can immediately Jump and Go which also
allows you to make adjustment on their
proficient you faster and so as a quick
side note to this because this is
something that I've given a lot of
thought if you look at the top sales
people and sales trainers and this is
going to drive Point Drive home the
point that I was making earlier about it
being much of it being born all right is
that if you look at the top people who
are in the space you look at Jordan
Belfort right you look at Bradley you
look at and some people would would say
me in term from a selling perspective
all the guys that I know who have taught
sales were exceptional sales people day
one Bradley started selling cars when he
was 18 years old and was the top
salesman at 18 years old when he started
and he was like I just found something I
was really good at Jordan Belfort talks
about how you didn't know how to train
anybody in his book and then all of a
sudden he for the first time ever wrote
out a framework to explain the straight
line sale system which became his book
and all that kind of stuff but he up to
that point it was just what he naturally
did right and I can tell you in my
instance as well I'd already closed
thousands of deals before I even
consumed my first sales training and so
like I I do think that if we are
selecting sales people I think it's much
more about selection than it is about
training the training is to remind them
how good they are not necessarily to
make them good all right and this is
something that has shifted over time for
me specifically now if you're like well
I suck at sales you can absolutely put
way more time into yourself than a
business would recently put into an
employee all right like you have you all
the time so you can train you in all
your off hours and you're spending your
own time to invest in yourself but from
a return on investment perspective it's
the cost of finding a good salesperson
compared to the cost of training a bad
or mediocre sales person is
significantly lower it's much easier to
find the right people than it is to take
somebody and then make such a crazy
extensive training unless your entire
model is we just take on every single
person who walks in the door like 24
Hour Fitness has this model they take on
anybody who has a pulse and then they
put them through a ridiculous culling
process and then 10 of people make it in
the first 90 days I've said this quote
many times in our communities and on
this channel which is you must outwork
yourself down right if you feel like you
are not confident then you must outwork
the things that you're insecure about if
you're like man I'm selling these
services and I'm not sure I'm not sure
if I'm that good at them then do more of
them and don't pretend
honesty is one of the most compelling
and convicting things for persuading
people right saying what you are good at
and what you are not good at truthfully
will we knew far more followers and fans
and and loyal customers and loyal
employees than pretending because the
end of the day they can feel that you
are disingenuous because they know that
is hollow they know that on the inside
you do not believe the words that are
coming out of your mouth and that is how
people speak without conviction and they
cannot sway others because they have not
swayed themselves because they have lost
their own respect and so I am not the
believer in buying the Ferrari when you
can't afford it I am not the believer in
in affording the home and paying for the
home that you cannot afford because you
want to pretend like this is the
lifestyle that you want to be around if
you go into the guise of networking you
can still go to those places without
buying a four million dollar house when
you you're barely making you know a few
hundred thousand dollars it doesn't make
sense I like Jay-Z's quote around this
which is if you can't buy something
twice don't buy it once I really like
that and so
this is one of the most common questions
I get for newer entrepreneurs because
they think that they have to they have
to they have to pose on Instagram in
order to get to to get wealthy and what
it does is it conflates sequence Jeff
Bezos is famous because of what he did
not because he became famous as Jeff
Bezos and then used his following to
build something Elon Musk is famous for
what he's accomplished not for being
Elon Musk and then creating something as
a result right let the actions be the
thing that gives you the fame rather
than yourself right at least that is
that is Alex's two cents in my viewpoint
in the world and I think most of Mosey
Nation you guys uh share that belief
with me and for those of you who are new
to this channel
um you're going to get more of this type
of stuff uh and none of the Fig until
you make it nonsense that is a sure way
uh to be broke and I will tell you this
as a last thing
the amount of people who in 2008 when
everything crashed who were faking it
until they quote made it
just faked it until they lost it all
because they lost what little amount
that they had because they were so
overextended but I can tell you that
just about everyone can become wealthy
if you choose to live on Lower unless
than you make right and that is a ratio
wealth is a ratio not a number all right
and so anywho if you are having
struggles with this question I would
pause it I would I would beg of you that
you build your own respect first that
you're honest with yourself first and if
you always maintain the Integrity of hey
last year we we got smashed right this
year we'll do a little bit better and
two years from now when you do even
better than that you can be truthful and
people will believe you but if you
always are telling a story about how
you're always doing so well hey everyone
will hate you B no one cares and C you
will know that you are full of it and at
the end of the day I think that is the
only thing that we're going to keep with
us and when we die once everyone's going
to forget about us anyways so you might
as well at least enjoy yourself while
you're alive most people most Champions
do not have something that you do not
have they lack something that you have
or a champion in the Physical Realm a
lot of times it's they don't have an off
switch they just keep going you have an
off switch their lack of it which is
what drives their success and so to the
same degree you probably do things every
single day that you should not be doing
and so what I want to introduce to you
is a concept of the anti-routine as the
most productive routine that is humanly
possible for you to accomplish what you
want so number one is obviously just
shifting the perspective of I need to do
more things and I need to add more
things to my routine when in fact you
need to stop doing things that you're
currently doing all that remains is the
work to be done and then you become very
clear about why you are not being
affected so number one is that
priorities mean two things cannot be
equally important and here's the
mentally challenging thing about this is
that when you work on something unless I
spend 30 minutes on this thing and I
spend 30 minutes on the item bit if I
spend 30 minutes on both things and I
say this one's more important than this
one I can say that but that's not
reality because I basically just said
they were both important which means
neither of them are which is why most
people cannot get done because they
cannot say no a lot of people don't need
a new things to add to the routine you
need to have a routine of saying no an
anti-routine and that is the thing
that's going to yield those outsized
Returns on productivity you can't say
yes to everything and therefore it means
that you can't do two things with
different levels of importance it's
either important or it's not important
if it's important it means it means you
say no to everything else so if you say
this is the priority then it means you
do not do other things besides that
thing that is how out is a priority that
is how you literally prioritize I would
say there are days that I feel like less
energized or things like that for sure
not about like the big picture of like I
don't believe that this cause is not
worthy but I do think a lot of people
have that too where they're like what
I'm doing is meaningless right and then
I get into I think everything's
meaningless and then we can just create
whatever meaning you know we choose to
because if we don't believe in a capital
M meeting which a lot of people disagree
with that's fine but if you don't
believe in a capital N meaning I think
that's very freeing because then you can
create Little M meaning for whatever you
want and so if you believe you can then
choose to architect your own life in
whatever ways that you deem meaningful
and make the activities you do aligned
with that meeting the difference between
capital M meaning and Little M meaning
and this is kind of like the basis of
nihilism which people have like a very
negative Viewpoint around which I'm not
entirely sure about why but like capital
a meeting means that like this is the
meaning of life period like for everyone
this is the meaning of life whereas if
we say that there is no single agreed
upon meaning of life and then people say
well then that is your big mean of life
and I'm like yes you're right I believe
that there is no meaning that is the
meaning that I that I believe and
they're like well then that is the
capital then sure that's my capital M
meaning is that there is no meaning
what's the implication of that it means
now that we have meaning making machines
in our brain and so we get to create and
Destroy meaning as we see fat and so if
we choose an activity and we deem that
goal meaningful because we think it's
more interesting or it energizes us then
we can ascribe meaning to that and do
more of it and what's nice about not
having capital M meaning is that that
can shift right that might be good for a
season and then it can shift I will say
that the downside of not having capital
M meaning which I consider to be
religion off the shelf is that it's more
difficult because you have no one who's
saying here's the big box of rules you
can read it and then that way you don't
have to make the decisions about it but
I think it's more difficult but and
ultimately more rewarding if you have
reasoning behind why you believe what
you believe because then you have to
independently come up with your own
conclusions about those things it also
makes it malleable so that if you get
new data or new evidence then you can
change your mind which a lot of people
again have difficulty with but like if
you change the information then it would
make sense that if it materially changes
the outcome that the way that you
believe about something should change
and I think a lot of people will
identify with their beliefs as a part of
themselves rather than as what I prefer
to call them which is assumptions
because they work the same way what's
the difference in belief and assumption
not a lot right the only difference is
just what we call the word and so
assumptions are based on things that
we've observed and then we assume
something as a result and so I would say
that beliefs are just assumptions and
but when you call them that they become
less tied to your identity if you have
an assumption you don't say you
challenged my assumption it's like well
yeah I challenge my assumption Ah that's
great I I was assuming this it must be
this and then they become much more
flexible and then we don't tie our egos
into them and I think ultimately it
serves more people better in the long
run a lot of people I would say
mistakenly think that the number one
resource is time
right everyone's like time is money time
is money time is money
and I would argue that that's not
necessarily true I would argue that
attention is money that is the golden
resource so the billionaire friend that
I have he's actually uh been helping me
on um the new Endeavor that we are
launching to our gym alerts uh soon
which I think will change the industry
anyways he's been helping me with that
stuff but like here's an example on his
phone his phone does not ring unless you
are already a contact that has been
whitelisted his phone doesn't ring it's
he's impossible to reach the more
successful the more the the larger your
company grows the more you scale the
more you need to scale the only way to
scale you is because you do have a
finite amount of attention and so what
happens is you have to decrease all of
the other things in your life that drain
attention because you can have as much
time as you want but if you're not there
you're not potent you're not able then
you can't get anything done with that
time that you're supposedly allocating
which is why a lot of people end up in
this in between state of always
everywhere and at the same time nowhere
right and so they're they're everywhere
but they're not paying attention to
anything and that's and the reason that
it's difficult to focus is because
entrepreneurs the character trait that
made us into entrepreneurs is that we're
go-getters we're we're risk averse we're
creators we're innovators we're Builders
right we have all of those traits but
the difficulty is is that the thing that
gets you from zero to one is not the
thing that gets you from one to two
right and so one of the the reason that
you have to totally morph and why you
have to be a growth oriented individual
is because you have to change your own
individual character traits in order to
progress as a business owner and so like
I said the things that got you here are
not the things that are going to get you
there the things that got you here which
is your own internal skills are not the
things that you need to pass on to other
people so the only way that you were
able to grow your business at a certain
point is by growing other people right
and the only way you can do that is if
you have the attention and the bandwidth
in order to do so and that's why if you
look at a business owner and like the
more I obsess on looking at billionaires
and people who are doing better than we
are is I look at how quiet and how clean
they keep their space and I mean that
both in a literal sense that like their
surroundings their office their house
their homes their cell phone their
computers right there it's it's it's
quiet right everything like it's it's
pristine and when you talk to these
people there's a certain amount of of
Tranquility that's there and
and they just they just have very low
tolerance and it's not that they're
trying to be impatient with you or
impatient with the world it's just that
they understand that they have so like
they're they're operating at such a high
level that there's so many things that
are demanding of their time and
attention that they just like they can't
and so they have to forcibly remove
themselves from so many different
situations and I'm going to give you an
example so one of the people that I'm
I'm somewhat mentoring right they had
they had four businesses and this is
something that happens so many times it
lit like like you want you want a
hundred thousand dollar coaching this is
what happens in 100 000 coaching
sessions and I'm being honest with you
what happens is someone who's coming in
usually doing between one and three
million dollars a year
um can't get past a certain point right
and the reason they can't get past this
because they only have so much attention
and if it's spread between four or five
different kids that's when the gym owner
has four gyms and is making less money
than they did when they had one gym
because the amount of attention that
they can allocate to one facility has
gone down so much that with fixed costs
they basically are breaking even right
and so the same thing happens now that
entrepreneur is probably making one to
three million in gross revenue but not
taking anything home because they don't
have the attention to actually put onto
things and so in order to grow you need
to do less
in order to grow you need to do less and
that comes from both delegation and also
choosing what not to do the better you
get the better the opportunities that
you have to say no to imagine the level
of opportunities that we have now I'm
just being honest so imagine how many
things we could do or try and JV with or
do a partnership with or whatever
because of the distribution Network that
we have and the trust and the Goodwill
that we have with the gym owners
um that we have in our Network right a
lot I get I you know how many people
cold message me like I have an
opportunity for you I'm like really you
have an opportunity for me and so the
better you get the better your
opportunities you have to say no to
which is why becoming a higher and
higher and higher level entrepreneur is
more and more difficult because it
requires discipline
it's not about doing more it's about
doing less because we innately want to
do more so doing more of your own
internal characteristic if that was what
it took to get to be more successful
then everyone would be more successful
because it would be something that does
not take effort because that is
something that we already do it's like
man I outwork anyone I've got all this
work ethic cool that gets you from zero
to one
it's not going to get you any further
than that so stop identifying with that
it was something that I used to identify
with I was like I'll I'll outwork anyone
or whatever like that was something that
I used to think about and it was a
character trade it was an identity thing
and the more you grow the more you
realize that your identity needs to be
fluid because what it needs to be is
exactly what it needs to be at that
given time of development because the
character traits that I'm going to have
to emphasize in a year are going to be
different than the ones that I have to
emphasize now the skills that you need
to learn like delegation leadership
those are things that are not the things
that take you in the beginning you have
to be independent you have to be
hustling you have to be grinding you
have to be willing to put in the work
because no one else will do it for you
especially if you have no Capital to
start which most people who are on here
are in that situation to reel this back
in the number one thing that you have to
be paying attention to is where you are
paying your attention
right like you spend attention that's
why they call it paying attention it's
because it is a resource and most people
don't pay attention to that right and so
one of the things that a lot of people
don't know about me this one's going to
go along
um
some of the things that a lot of people
don't know about me is that I for nine
months paid a coach to teach me one
thing which was to manage my attention
was to teach me how to think and so for
90 minutes every single day all I did
was talk about what I was thinking about
think about that
every day I paid attention to where my
attention was
and when I did that all of a sudden my
business blew up right and I realized
that I had toxic relationships I had
toxic relationships with parents I had
toxic relationships with friends or
pseudo friends things that I that were
taking my attention past things that I
had on my mind that I knew I had not
handled so those are called like open
Loops or open Cycles right so when you
have something that you like I haven't
resolved this and you need to handle
that and you'll get that attention back
because what happens is you have this
bowl this tiny little bowl of marbles
that each of those marbles is is a unit
of attention right if you had to measure
it and so you put little marbles of
attention on your childhood promise you
put little marbles of attention on your
marriage you put little uh marbles of
attention on your health you put little
marbles of attention on your
spirituality and then massive marbles of
attention on your business but the thing
is is that sometimes you need to quiet
and collect all of these other little
marbles so that you have more potency
more potential energy more potential
units of attention to spend on the one
thing that you're trying to grow which
in this case would be your business and
what's interesting is that what happens
is that things that were perceived as
difficult become really easy and I don't
know if you've ever had this happen but
like if you were in college or you were
in high school and you were like man I
can't solve this problem this math
problem and you were exhausted then you
go to bed and you wake up the next
morning and then all of a sudden it
seems really easy or you're like I don't
know why I didn't see that before
because attention gives you the ability
to see
right like if you're if you think about
wisdom right wisdom is an ability to see
what other people cannot see right two
people are presented the same situation
the wiser person sees things that the
other person does it and how can you see
better you see better if you have more
ability to see which comes from your
most valuable resource attention how
much horsepower do you have and so look
at the things that you have in your in
your life right now like if I see
someone who has a messy relationship
life who's got a messy love life who
goes out of your weekend and gets
trashed right like I can tell you
billionaires don't do that that like the
whole Tony Stark like vision of the
entrepreneur is a farce it's not true
don't believe that every single
billionaire every single high-level
entrepreneur is quiet
unbelievably quiet they keep themselves
completely isolated they have a bubble
around them of of layers of protection
they're like like for me it's it's me
and then there's Layla and then we have
our CEO and then we have our executive
assistant team because we have a team of
EAS at this point we have four
um who work the next level there's no
one who has direct access to me
including our employees no one does and
that's because it's it would disserve
you you guys our gym owners if everyone
had access to me the reason that I don't
respond to Facebook messages is not
because I don't want to it's because I
literally can't and if I did I would be
disturbing everyone because then my
attention would be split because someone
can't generate leads in their mind or
whatever you know what I mean like
because these little things these little
things that are perceived as huge issues
to you in that moment because you have a
little bit of attention you you have so
little left that everything seems like
an explosion but when you have lots of
capacity City big problem seems small
and small problems seem big and it
sounds reverse because what you do is
you start seeing that all of these
things are attention drains and you just
say I don't want to play anymore
and you stop playing
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from Dean graziosi
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there listen don't wait
for permission from your husband from
your parents from your children from
anyone remember God gave it to you not
them the universe gave it to you not
them you see I really believe sometimes
our subconscious